[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody it's now 1pm
and we'll call the meeting of the
district planning regulation committee
to order
um apologies i have no apologies apart
from council blacky has to leave at 3
20 which is duly noted
and are there any conflicts of interest
for this meeting
appear to be none confirmation of
minutes held on the 18th of august 2020.
do i have any um in a move and a
seconder for that
councillor atkinson moves councillor
redmond seconds
either is there any discussion i'll put
that all those in favor please say aye
against declare that carried is there
any matters arising
to the minutes appear to be none
we have no deputations today so we'll
bring our first report up 6.1
matt bacon for the plan change 45
ranger airfield welcome to the table
matt
thanks before i race up just my pleasure
to introduce everyone to
tim johnson so tim johnson's our new
graduate partner that starts with us
uh we'll start with us three weeks ago
now um so it's first committee
and tim effectively replaces jen uh
russell who is
uh going on maternity leave um so for
those that have seen her recently you'll
be very clear why and so tim joins us
for that time and a little bit of time
afterwards
um to cover us while we're going through
the district plan
uh review process so tim um comes to us
from well just recently graduated but
comes to us having done some work at the
city council and also at inspire um
which is a
consultancy firm mainly based out of
tower remember that a lot of work down
here
in terms of local as well which is
another great thing to see lives in
silverstone
welcome to tim as our new staff member
excellent thank you so i i don't have uh
too much to say on the report i think
it's pretty much taken as read
uh it's it's good that we've reached the
process by which we can now make the
provisions operative it's taken slightly
longer than we
anticipated it would but it's uh
certainly got there and it is is a good
result
have confirmed as well we we we aren't
aware of any
appeals having come through the
environment court given that they closed
late last week as well so i'm happy to
take the reporters read and to answer
any questions
are there any questions on the report
there appear to be none is anyone happy
to move the report
council award moves counselor atkinson
seconds
council award thank you
um this is a very good progress and and
very delighted to receive this
designation
to the ring of the ranger airfield and
so hopefully we can progress
in the future along lots of positive
ways
councilor atkinson any other speakers
just quickly speaking to it as chair um
thank you very much matt and your team
for
the work on this i know it's been quite
a long process but this is a highly
significant asset in our district
and it's been recognised for its
strategic importance in canterbury
and so this is the end of a long process
and um
looking forward to the fact that this
becomes operative in november
right is there no food or any right to
reply council award
thank you thank you right i'll put the
report as it is on your order paper all
those in favor please say i
against i'll declare that carried thank
you man
moving to 6.2 the proposed property
bylaw
maintenance bylaw nick harrison thank
you thank you madam chair
look kay is kindly distributing a hard
copy of the
proper version of the bylaw counselor
redmond identified that the one which
went out in the agenda was
one generation ago so my apologies for
that but
the new version is there
i won't say much about the bylaws we're
all familiar with this committee it's
been here back in august and the
committee referred it back to the
hearing committee
particularly about just being clear in
the definition of long grass
and the hearing committee reconvened and
came back with
20 centimetres as being the
the length if you like for long grass
the other matters that the hearing
committee was asked to clarify were just
to remove some words in section three of
the bylaw
um around nuisance and also in section
4.5
where it sought the removal of the words
create a habitat suitable for vermin to
live and breed
because those matters are actually dealt
with by the health act
in that way there's also a subsequent or
consequential amendment to the bylaw
just over in 7.1 which is actually the
breach of the bylaw part
is just the insertion of the word long
in front of grass
just so that it more clearly defines or
makes
clear the matter being
enforced if you like if the committee
adopts the resolutions it then goes
to the council to adopt the bylaw and
then
at some time after that the council set
a date for it to be operative
thank you madam chair thank you are
there questions on the bylaw
a counselor mailings it's not so much of
a question but is this the final draft
or will there be some more proof reading
done of it because
i can just see a wee spot that needs
some attention
would you like to stay with you in that
in that 7.1
it reads in addition to the powers
conferred on it by any other enactment
an authorized person may
long grass or other vegetation
yeah so may may do what with it a person
in this one a person may arrange to have
yes we need those words in there
arranged you have
yeah they're in there yes
yes thank you thank you canceler
mailings i've also i noted some other
words in there that needed to change in
there
like
oh it's still crossed out okay oh look
it's confusing with this number of my
bad
great it looks good to me so we'll we'll
leave
um mr harrison to make that final
amendment to the vinyl are there any
other questions
um i've just got one mr harrison on
section 6.1 the financial implications
um in paragraph four you've stated it
could be argued that the costs on
balance
of just mowing the sections are more
acceptable than applying the weight of a
by-law to the
issue however it's unknown how this
issue will develop
and that there could be more complaints
have you received
in your experience to date are there
complaints increasing or
decreasing for this issue
we've only received a handful of
complaints over the last couple of years
to do with the bylaw um complaints will
be seasonal
so if we have a wet spring um or an
early wet summer yes you could expect to
have some more complaints
and you could even expect to have some
complaints near the end of summer if
uh long grass is left to go to seed but
we have it's only a limited number of
complaints we've actually received
so is that statement actually saying
that it's more costly to have a bylaw
than
to actually mow the property
it might it might be a bit late for that
argument in a way
because we've actually gone down this
path no i mean the operational costs
going forward oh
no sorry no um no it won't be and the
operational costs going forward
uh if we got the same number of
complaints um
a staff member would go out there
ascertain whether it's a breach of the
bylaw or not
ask for it to be remedied if it wasn't
remedied there is a cost recovery
facility in the bylaw
so operation operational costs
are likely to actually be less than not
having a bylaw
right thank you for that um is someone
prepared to
move something for this
the mayor's prepared to move and
councillor even all second the mayor
thank you madam chair but there's been
quite a lot of we had a lot of
discussion in the last meeting about
this but
this eventuated because of it came about
from feedback from the community
who were frustrated um by the fact of
long
grass on sections and there were a
number of instances where
this was happening and effectively the
council had no ability
which to address it so um i
did some homework uh i've worked with
our staff to identified
identify where there are other instances
in the country where this has occurred
and how they've handled it
the closest jurisdiction that we found
was
auckland and they came in place with a a
property maintenance
a nuisance by laura i think they called
it up there
we then went about we consulted with all
the community boards
and there was consultation with um the
community as well
and that's what's eventually brought
back this i'm actually pleased that the
um because it had gone quite broad
uh and outside what was its original
intention which was to deal with
grass and other vegetation and that's
exactly what
is the measure to be dealt with here
it's a pity we need to look at matters
like this if owners would take care of
their own sections
and didn't create um the associated
nuisance then we wouldn't need to be
considering this
the law also when when the parliament
changed the rules and
fins the new law came about which
brought about
fire emergency in new zealand it took
away the ability of council to be able
to consider such matters
and i think that was an unintended
consequence to a degree
because as we found out finn's actually
not particularly interest unless it
creates a direct fire risk
um we do have a number of instances
around where we do have
situations that come up having a bylaw
in place
hopefully would act as a deterrent
hopefully we wouldn't have to take that
step
but if we do we're armed with that
ability in which to do that
and that was the whole reason for
bringing this about so we're confining
it back to what its original purpose
i'm actually happy with and support
councillor edmund thank you madam chair
um this my law is mr mayor has indicated
has had a long gestation period
and has been simplified over its um
course that went from an amenity by law
to really effectively along grass by law
i thought i'd just show you
the length of grass you're allowed above
my finger
200 or what is it 20 centimeters
um i haven't been around to check your
lawns
i think the main effect of this bylaw is
going to be a deterrent effect
i think it's probably going to be very
rarely used
and when it is used we may have to
balance
whether it would be cheaper to take
remedial action ourselves or rely on the
buy law
the bylaw does enable us to recover
reasonable costs
from the landowner but again i think
it'll be really you
so it's on the books um and i think
it'll be used with um
a touch of common sense so i'm happy to
second that i think it's uh
a step in the right direction the
amenity by law is something different
that could be something that may be
looked at in the future
thank you are there any further speakers
uh councillor becky
um when when it went back to the
subcommittee wendy and
sandra and myself we had to figure out
what was the definition of long grass
and we looked at each other for a while
and said well
it's about where it starts to clog your
right on mower and then someone said
well how long's that
and we said actually it's that long
so that is the highly scientific way
that we decided on
the length of of long grass that is the
definition of long grass
a name tag on end
any further speakers counselor mailings
just looking at this i i am pleased to
see that it has been pulled back to just
talk about grass and specifically on
undeveloped residential zone prop
residential zone properties um and i do
note
that in 6.1 where it says it could be
argued that the costs are on balance
more acceptable
than applying the weight of a bylaw to
the issue um
it is unknown how the the issue will
develop if if it becomes known that oh
yeah i just let it grow long and um the
council will just come and mow it for
you and we have no way to recover that
cost then that could become a problem so
this
actually nips that in the bud it gives
us the ability to recover any of those
costs and actually keep the problem in
check
so um i'm i'm quite happy with
this final draft as it is now written
because it is
it is specifically targeted at what it
was originally meant
to do so i'm happy to support it
any further speakers um just speaking to
it myself
um i'm very pleased with the revised
version of it i think it is
taking it back to the original issue i
was really worried about the neighbor
war
issue i've had a comment recently that a
person mentioned that they were
essential worker working full-time and
they had a person ring the council about
their grass going on to the footpath
whereas they could have just come over
and knocked on their door and talked to
them and i don't i think it's important
that council doesn't take over
from civil issues because that is not
our mandate
and however i i still can't accept that
this bylaw
is actually going to make any difference
which is why i will vote against it
um i think it was good to investigate
the issue and it's really important that
we go through those issues and i know
the panel worked exceptionally hard
but the fact that the panel was not
unanimous showed that there was a great
deal of contention
in this issue the fact that we've had to
send it back for redefinition
shows that it's very difficult to put
into law
we've already we've removed nuisance
we've removed the vermin we've now said
over 20 centimetres of grass which is an
arbitrary figure
um we've gone back to undeveloped
residential
zone sections so this is not an
all-encompassing
by-law it's a very very specific one but
council law
the the laws that council can enact as a
regulatory body are set by
central government and local government
doesn't have the power
to easily recoup costs even with a bylaw
we rely on the court process for that
and as has been stated by councillor
redmond
the cost of doing so can be highly
prohibitive
so my concern is that there is already
law particularly in pegasus where this
issue started
covenants it's civil law and if a person
is upset with a person breaching a civil
covenant
they should take a civil case it's not
council's responsibility to do so
so i believe we're sending the wrong
signal to the community
we're sending a signal that the council
can fix anything
and i'm very worried about the effect on
staff
staff trying to go out and actually
affect cost recovery
on mowing a small handful of
long grass sections in our district
is going to be very very difficult for
them
so there is a cost and there is a
nuisance issue to staff
in the fact that they will become
involved in an area that is not
council's responsibility
it is a civil issue the feedback from
the community when this bylaw came
through
was actually about nuisance it was about
cars
parked on sections it was about
containers it was about fireworks it was
about noise
it wasn't necessarily just about long
grass
and i still see long grass as a civil
issue and not one that should
require an entire bylaw to cover it so i
will not be voting for this
recommendation going forward
right of reply thank you i think it's
been
um well stated by colleagues and what
actually brought this about
was in fact an unfortunately a civil
situation that wasn't ensuring in the
particular neighborhood that was
investing
a lot of staff time governance time as
well
and there was effectively a a little war
going on
at the very time and so at the time i i
looked into this to see
what was appropriate what other steps
could we take
um and um and also i did consult with
staff about the options of this so
i feel comfortable with where we've got
to i feel comfortable
that it's come back to in confined to
its original intention because that's
where we got the original feedback from
both
residents from pegasus particularly here
in rangiora there are a number of
instances
there's one going in kaiapoi currently
and also from the feedback from our
boards
it got broadened as we went out and also
when we asked staff
what what other things should we
consider in there and
a whole raft of other things came in
there so in actual fact um
confining it back to its intent to its
original intention
is the right thing to do i hope that we
don't have to go through a court process
and i hope that this acts as a
as a suitable deterrent in that people
take care of their own sections
it would that that would fix it all uh
if people did
take care of it unfortunately there are
instances where it doesn't and people
get pretty hit up if you're in
neighborhoods around it
this is simply a tool for our staff to
have in the toolbox
if needed and i'm hope i'm hopeful that
it would just be a deterrent
i don't really necessarily want to see
us go down the court process
and test that because it's rightly
observed by council of arnold and
councillor redmond there's a cost
involved in that i think personally that
to have this in the box
as a tool i think will be helpful to our
staff
and hopefully it doesn't become an
owner's burden for them
right everyone has spoken i'll put the
motion as it is in your order paper all
those in favor please say aye
against against i declare that carried
i'd like my vote recorded thank you
moving on to 6.3
thank you mr harrison sorry moving on to
6.3 heritage biodiversity ecological
fund allocations
gina and ian will be presenting today
welcome to the table and take your time
[Laughter]
gina
if you just like to turn the microphone
on that would be great thank you
good afternoon today i have put in a
report under their heritage
biodiversity and ecological fund i would
just like to make a few comments in
relation to the applications we have
received
we have received two applications
covering three projects
one of the projects
was complete in 2017 by sharon leach
which
is the
painting of broadhaven
and she approached staff at the time
in relation to receiving some help with
funding
however due to staffing we weren't able
to
run a funding round for her
um so she was recommended by staff to
come when we did open the fund and do it
retrospectively
normally we don't do it retrospectively
her second application is for re-roofing
of
the property a lean-to and a garage
after speaking with staff
they have recommended that due to the
funds
including the fact that the lean-to and
garage are not considered
heritage and not protected that we offer
to fund
50 of the works of
just the house and the third application
came to me towards the end of last year
however due to
waiting for other applications to come
in a little bit of covert and my
injury she's actually in june she
completed the painting herself
and the damage to the wood was actually
less so her quotes were ten
thousand and twelve thousand dollars
approximately
and it's actually coming at just over
so hers is retrospectively in the fact
that we haven't been able to process
it
comments um i'd just like to add to that
so
both buildings are category two heritage
listed buildings
um what they have in common to all is
historical uh architectural
group and setting significance however
the
brooklyn's cottage at rangiora wooden
road
has additional landmark and
craftsmanship
significance
take the reporter's red thank you gina
are there any questions
for the panel councillor ridman followed
by councillor stewart
thank you madam chair um could you just
clarify
for me what is the policy do we do a
hundred percent
of the cost or do we have a policy of 50
which i saw referred to in the report
previously
we have done 50
however i brought it to you
last year and because of the
funding that was available and the
projects
we authorized up to a hundred percent
i guess it's up to your discretion
just to follow up we have a certain
amount of funds
in this account uh
when does that get topped up again
we receive 15 500
and we receive it at the beginning of
each financial year
councillor stuart isn't that does that
answer your questions councillor edmund
thank you councillor stewart thank you
um
just a question on process um i was part
of
um a hearing panel that considered
several of these
last year yes and i just wonder
what triggers a panel and what goes to
staff
what's the process we decided on a panel
last time because
we hadn't done a funding round since
2008 and we had
16 applications so it was agreed that
having
a funding panel to go through the 16
applications and spend that time
dedicated to them
um would be time better spent than
having it
brought to dpnr for all 16 applications
and merits and
etc to be discussed
that because you had more than one or
two
you decided a panel correct so so how
many
what's the policy how many do we have
before we trigger a panel because i'm
i'm
quite interested in having the um
counsellor input to these departments
apart from just you know being brought
to the committee
i would say if we
went over five we would probably request
a panel just for the as i say that the
time it takes
to go through each application i think
mint may have some comments for us here
thank you
oh
thank you sharon thank you council
stewart i thought just uh just to add
to uh gina's answer and to give a little
bit of context to the
um to the to the fund we're currently
looking at
um the option of splitting the fund from
um to be a separate heritage fund and a
separate biodiversity and
ecological fund and in doing that we
will bring um the option of doing that
back to the committee or to
to committees actually because it's also
going to go to land water committee
and that will look at also the criteria
for funding so we'll bring forward some
options and that might be workshopped
around what criteria we want to see for
funding
and that question can be part of the the
conversation as well
the other thing will be some options
around funding that so
myself and grant mccloud are looking at
the funding options there and we'll
bring those back as well
in terms of the funding around it will
it's being done as part of the ltp
um process so very shortly is the answer
we
we need to meet and discuss that uh in
terms of the options around splitting
the fund and how that works
we haven't programmed that in yet but
it's likely to be
sort of start of next year i'd imagine
question from me
so is it fair to say that the report
that's been brought to us today looking
through it
has been applications that were delayed
through the covert 19 emergency
and has made it difficult to have
meetings with the panel or the chair of
dpnr to
discuss these issues
i was really lucky that she was able to
bring it through to get the funding
through
so any sense of what you are what you're
recommending to us today is a
a tidy up of the 2020 year
and there are are there any other
outstanding applications in the 2020
year at this point
no i'm not aware of any at the moment
thank you any further questions
councillor edmund
thank you madam chair the application
for retrospective
repainting of the exterior uh that
painting was carried out in 2007
i realised there have been delays with
covert and other matters
but what explains the
rest of the delay of two years sharon
leech
the planning department in relation to
the contestable fund as it was called
back before she completed the painting
however due to staff resourcing they
weren't actually able to hold
a funding round for her as it was done
every
three years so
when she spoke to staff they advised if
she
painted it and we would look at the
application retrospectively because
there wasn't any funding
we weren't able to do a funding round
for her at that time
council emily would it be fair to say
that that this is an absolute exception
to the rule
because in the guidelines it says that
the fund isn't available to compensate
for work already done
correct can i'm not leaning that way by
the way
i just i was just thinking that that
with this should we
go ahead with this that i think it needs
to be noted that this particular one
is quite an exception so as not to open
floodgates for other people to come in
with retrospective things and we very
clearly said that yeah
as the fund is not available we'll let
councillor
will let mr bacon apply to that i think
question thank you
no sorry
oh again i'm just for further context on
that one yes so
um the resourcing of the fund has set
sort of rather uncomfortably between a
number of teams for a number of years
but
just in terms of this particular um
application the
um epcon actually was talking to us
before we made a decision around respect
to funding
and at the time we were still debating
whether or not we would hold it at
a retrospective funding or not so on the
basis that they'd already spoken to us
before
the committee had made a decision to
move to respective funding we had said
look it's reasonable for us to consider
it as it was at the time
gina just to clarify you mentioned about
the lean to in the garage on one
application
not not being part of the heritage
assessment can you just clarify the
figures that you've got in the
recommendation and the report for us as
to what you're asking for today
so sharon um brought to us two
two quotes however they're not identical
the first one was for just over 24 000
and that was for the replacement of the
garage lean to
and the house the second application
was for the lean-to garage house but
included scaffolding that they needed
done
so bearing in mind how much we have
available in the fund
after discussions we the staff
recommended
that the funding would be 50 percent
of the
just the garage roof replacement which
would be half of the
the twenty four thousand seven hundred
and thirty six fifty
and again it is um we would love to fund
more but we just need to be mindful of
the balance in any future projects that
we may
have coming up
councillor atkinson thank you clarify
further
the lean-to and the garage are not part
of the historic yet we are funding
to fix something that's not part of the
historic 50 percent
she's applied for the house the garage
and the lean to
we're recommending 50 of just the house
so that's contained in the
recommendation of c effectively those
numbers there
equate to that recommendation just
remind me that that is the case yes
correct thank you
that's what i thought it was are there
any other questions
i'm happy to test the meeting and move
the recommendation as it's stated in 6.3
do i have a seconder mr mia
just speaking to the report there's
obviously
um it's been difficult to follow total
process this year there's been a quite a
change in the way we meet and the way we
progress and it's obvious that this fund
still needs some further work as
has been indicated by mr bacon um so it
looks like we will be receiving a
further report to tidy up and clarify
what this fund is going forward but at
this point we've had some people in good
faith who have actually
performed restoration of heritage
buildings which are very important in
our district
and we do have funds available which are
sitting in the fund to be spent
and and i trust the staff
recommendations to have identified the
areas
that are covered by the heritage
designation so i'm happy to
approve this report for the thirty one
thousand and thirty six dollars and
eleven cents
as of today uh to try and tidy up uh the
issues that we've had over the past
few years in this area and hopefully
from here we will receive further
direction which can then go to the panel
which has been set up of elected members
um to actually
have a broader discussion when these
applications come in so i want to thank
the staff for getting us through this
period
and for finding for bringing this report
to us and hopefully
we can see the benefit of this heritage
work being done in our district
thank you mr man support
your comments madam chair just like to
thank gina and ian for the work that's
gone in
um to this report i think it's it is
very clear and i appreciate the further
clarifications that have come from
colleagues and they are reasonable sums
of money
but this is exactly what this fund was
set up for
um having a further workshop or
discussion or
further report would be helpful i think
the more we can clarify the better
um because we've been on that journey
for um
well for a number of years and in fact
as was mentioned the application that
was put in 20
the work that was happened in 2017 it
was the view of the committee at the
time
that we set the fund aside and applied
every three years so there could be a
meaningful amount of money there
to apply from and we could look at um
measures at that time not accepting the
fact that property owners
do need to get on and do their
maintenance they don't need to they
don't want to see their properties
deteriorate
from painting so their time frames
aren't necessarily going to work without
so
on that basis i'm happy to accept that
retrospective application because it's
been our process and then
an individual's being able to comply
with it um so no i'm i'm
fully in support of the applications
that are there and
support the recommendation further
speakers
there's nothing to reply to so i'll put
the recommendation as it stands in your
order paper all those in favor please
say i
i against i'll declare that carried
thank you very much for your report
moving on to portfolio updates first is
district planning and development
and just very quickly from myself
we've had another meeting with the
district plan team to further refine the
work that's going to be done
in the briefings for november and
december we have asked that there is
significant pre-reading available to
members so that
the committee will have a chance to look
over the information
before coming to the briefing and then
can devise any questions
we are going to have to keep this very
much to time
so if there are significant issues we do
have a reserve day at the end
of the time on the 4th of december and
so the faster we move through the issues
the less time we would have to spend on
that 4th of december
for some of those individual issues but
you are also welcome if you see
anything in the information to talk to
the staff member consumed whose area it
represents
if you have a specific issue that needs
tidying
counselor mealings do you have anything
to add not really much to add to that
but just to point out that yes so that
friday is there in in reserve for
time off for good behavior if you will
so if we manage to actually get through
all the
the case matter then great and there
will be just one page
am i correct here um what one page um
reading per um there'll be a summary
yeah
a summary and then if you want to delve
into any issues yourselves then there
will be um information for you to go and
do that so we're not talking thousands
of pages of reading but
certainly um to come prepared because
there are a lot of things to get through
but
no i other than that have really nothing
to add let's get this thing done
please thank you councilman uh
councillor redmond
regulations you madam chair
um i'll refer to our four areas
the first one is planning we've
discussed the airfield plan change
at today's meeting so i won't comment
further on that the ravenswood plan
change is in process to be notified
around the end of the month this plan
change
seeks to re-zone about 13 hectares of
land to business one
when it was originally zoned residential
6a
and some of the business one zones
and the council had its october meeting
directed staff to notify the application
the somerset clan change uh the clark
property that decision came out
i think it was the end of last week and
the appeal period will close on the
first of december
the decision grants a re-zone of almost
14 hectares
from residential 4b to residential
2. a major part of this is to build a
retirement village and part of the
rezoned
land and if there are no appeals the
next step is
to report back to this committee to
adopt the change
and set an operative date
the fourth area in the planning area the
taggart
racecourse quarry application the
applicant's now requested that it be
notified
there is still some outstanding further
information to be provided so that when
the application is notified
people can understand it this is a joint
matter with ecan who will hear
submissions for the discharge
consent application civil defence
the cdem has been running emergency
operations centre courses for staff
and assisting the hiranui district
council
with a full day emergency operations
centre
annual exercise and training of
volunteers after hours
has continued and you may have noticed
in the management
team reports i think chris field was
commended for work he's been doing in
that area
along with brennan
building and i've mentioned this
previously
we're waiting on an mbie determination
on echo cottages
that's been with them for a long time
echo cottages sought
for a determination that their cottages
were not
buildings rather a collection of
building elements
and therefore no consent was required
sort of a novel argument
um there's no word on when that
determination will be published but it
has been a number of months
and just a general comment on building
activity it's actually about the same as
last year
and the building team is still doing
some work for salman
and ashburton councils which is helping
to balance
the workload and staff retention
the environmental services unit dogs
the team is following up those who have
not registered their dogs
and that number's come down to 254 dogs
out of a population of 12 686 dogs
it's amazing what statistics we can find
reasons for not registering are often
that the owner has left the district or
the dog has died
if the dog is still in the district then
an infringement fee of 300
can be issued and the last area is
alcohol hearings the wooden bottle shop
where a pizza takeaway is proposed to be
changed to a bottle store
and also big daddies in rangiora
are still set uh yet to be set down for
a hearing
the government's extended its covert
order that pushed out reporting times
for the
try agencies the ministry of health and
police to december
so this means the hearings can't be set
until the reports are available
and they have longer within which
to provide those reports so it's
unlikely those hearings will now be this
year
but that's outside our control so that's
just a roundup
from regulation and civil defence
thank you thank you councillor edmund
are there any questions on that report
i appear to be none very comprehensive
thank you very much
uh council award business promotion and
town centres
thank you um the business promotions
um rangiora have held a very successful
pop-up
meeting at the rsa which was very well
received
they've been very very busy planning and
getting underway with
the christmas parade a possible center
in conway lane we're looking at that
and and perhaps additional floats for
the rangiora parade
uh also applying
and having received some grants
from for the center parade 7306 from
suit
and having received
more funding for fireworks night
down here nine thousand three hundred
and eighty one dollars from southern
trust
um and they've received for celebration
night which is also happening in
rangiora
four thousand sixty-five dollars for
traffic management from
suit and for the celebration night
they've received funding from
writer foundation for seven thousand
dollars
so i guess what we can say
to that is that the wrangua promotions
has been
extremely active in gaining
funding for these additional funding
to hold these really great strategic
events for our district as far
as the town centres we've been doing a
lot of work
in that field with workshops and
looking at um of course lighting in the
town centers and
the painting and upgrading and skilling
of the kaikoi bridges of
foremost to get that sorted and decided
on before
lighting is planned for the kaipoy
area um also we've been having workshops
for the kharpui south business area
we've received five
proposals um for
uh to um to
have um what's going to happen in that
area
with um and of course
they were quite exciting proposals and
very extensive
from developers which is very helpful
for all for now and we've um we've we've
got it down to two
proposals but are now waiting for
further consultation and analysis
so um that's very very exciting so lots
of wonderful things happening
for kaya poor too so um that's
yeah very busy so it's been good you
have a question councillor atkinson
yeah my question is around the painting
of the bridge it's my understanding that
coyote community board's
waiting on a report on whether the
painting money
will end up in a ballast bellows
replacement or whatever that may be
to come back i'm interested to see why
we're
looking at lighting and painting the
bridge when that's
coming back the community board to be
decided on whatever
yet this appears to be discussions on
painting it
well we have had yeah we've had it is in
the pipeline we've had meetings on it
and have been in workshops
so maybe that um perhaps council award
and council like concern could have a
chat outside the meeting yes
discuss what's what's coming through
from both areas to see if we can have it
we have a sign delighting person to
thank you
to help us mr mayor just to say
um in support of uh council ankinson
that was my understanding too we had a
meeting with simon hart
end of last year on that very topic so
just
might pay to follow up assignment about
that joan thanks
thank you very much great any further
questions
there appear to be none i have no
questions i have no urgent general
business
so i will close the meeting as at 147
thank you for your attendance
right we'll now move into briefing
managers update
if anyone wants if nick wants to direct
this one i'll let you direct the traffic
thank you so
all much